INSTRUCTOR: All
right, so I'm going
to go ahead and record
Expo Lecture 1 material
in a more concise format here
for class and for easy review
and lookup.
I'll go ahead and share my
screen here to get started.
Some of these first
couple of topics
we've already covered
if you've been in class.
So if you have been,
and you're ready to get
into building and running the
app, you can go ahead and skip.
I'll put time stamps
in an announcement
so that you can skip to that
part of the video that's
relevant to you.
But yeah, to keep
it all in one place
and keep a concise
format here, I'll
go ahead and start from
the beginning with Expo.
So just for getting
started here,
we're going to run this
command to create a Expo app.
And I am going to be running
locally here on my machine.
But this is a Linux environment.
It's Linux Mint, which is
very similar to Ubuntu.
So everything will
be exactly the same.
Commands and such will
run exactly the same
as they would on
our EC2 instances.
The reason I'm
running locally is
for the mobile side
of this for Expo,
and I'll get to
that here in a bit.
But just to get
started, you will
want to run this command
to create your app--
npx create-expo-app@latest,
and I'll put that
in the announcement as well so
that you can copy it easily.
You don't have to
memorize anything here.
When you do that,
it'll be like, hey,
we're going to make
a new repo for you.
What do you want to call it?
Go ahead and call it
whatever you want.
I called mine expo
app to keep it simple.
Because this is all going
to be in a repo for you
to review and reference as
you're doing your homework,
that you would name this
whatever your project is,
like Andy would go baby-ninjas.
I'm just going to go ahead.
On our Ubuntu EC2 instances,
you should already
have node installed.
Check that you do.
I guess you have
to spell it right.
Node -v will give you
the version number.
And as long as it's 18 dot
something or newer, you're fine.
16 or older will not
work with Expo at all.
And then you'll be able to run
that npx create-expo-app@latest
command.
OK, so going on, jumping
into What is Expo?
A quick overview of Expo,
and I'll link the docs here.
Quick Start-- they've got that
command that I linked there npx
create-expo-app@latest.
And that'll get you started
with a new Expo repo.
And you can go
ahead and do that.
So I'll talk about
quickly what Expo is.
Expo is a framework that
is built on React Native.
And React Native is a framework
that adapted React.js.
React.js was made
by Meta, which would
use-- at the time was
Facebook, for creating
their dynamic, data-driven
social media app.
And that's what Expo and
React and React Native,
et cetera, is data-driven apps.
It allows you to build reusable
UI elements that render
differently, depending
on whatever data
you have available to
your app or for that user
or for that scenario.
And we'll go ahead
and show how to make
reusable portions
of your app and how
to make those data
dependent, data driven.
One of the best
things about Expo
is you can build
for web, mobile,
Android and iOS, both mobile
platforms, all with one code
base.
So you reduce the amount
of work that you're
doing to create an app to hit
as many users as possible,
or make your app available
to as many users as possible.
And if we go ahead, and
I'll open up the Expo
app that I made here.
And all I've done--
I haven't modified this at all.
I've literally just run the
npx create-expo-app command
and have this expo-app folder.
And I put this inside
my data5570 folder
so you can keep it in the same
repository as your Django app
side by side.
So you can see I've
got my Django app here,
and Expo is right next to it.
The virtual environment for
Django is also right next to it.
You do not have to have
a virtual environment,
your Python virtual environment
active to work in your Expo app.
Expo uses Node and
JavaScript libraries
and will not use any
Python libraries at all.
So once we've got that
installed, you'll see--
let me just open that--
Visual Studio code here.
Once we've got that
installed, you'll
see we've got a few things
here that it gives us out
of the gate.
First thing that you want to pay
attention to is node_modules.
It's just a giant folder
full of libraries and things
that you'll need to use
to build your Expo app
and be able to run it.
That is completely
generated for you,
so you should never edit
or anything directly
inside of node_modules.
It's all built depending on
the package.json configuration.
This list of dependencies
is what populates
the node_modules folder.
There are a few dependencies
I want to call attention to.
React-native-web
and react-dom are
the two main ones that we use
to make a React Native app,
be able to compile for web
and be able to run on web,
as well as React
Native for mobile.
Another one to pay attention
to that we'll get into today
is expo-router.
This sets up our routing
capability, which, in this case,
routing refers to how
the user navigates
between different screens.
So you'll start out on your
index screen or your default
screen.
And then they'll be able to want
to navigate to different screens
from there.
Expo-router handles that
logic, and it does it
in a pretty intuitive way.
I like it so far.
And then you'll get
several folders in here.
App is going to have the code
for our screens that we create.
Components is one.
You can place different
custom components,
reusable components in here.
Assets will hold things
like images or fonts,
custom elements like that.
So we have everything
that we need
to be able to run this on
mobile and web out of the box.
To do that, just go ahead
and open your terminal.
And you can use the EC2 terminal
that you connect with right
when you open it up.
Or you can create a
terminal in the VS Code web.
It's in a slightly
different spot.
You can use the VS Code Terminal
or your EC2 system terminal.
It doesn't really matter.
For visibility, I'm just going
to use my system terminal.
They function the
exact same way.
I'm going to run npm
start, and that's
going to go ahead and
run the Metro server.
Metro serves the
assets for our app,
and it'll give you
a QR code here.
And we'll get to that
here in just a second.
It'll also give you
some prompts and some
hotkeys you can press here.
So if I press W, it says
here that will open up web.
So that's popped open a browser
window, and it was pretty fast.
It might not be that fast for
you the first time you run it.
But what it did here is
it loaded router elements
and compiled our
web assets to be
able to render this on the web,
so built the website for us
right away.
And by default, this
is just what you'll
see with the default Expo app.
You've got an image here.
You've got some text.
And they use this
bottom tab navigator
by default, which
is a little bit
weird to do on web in
my opinion but works
great on mobile if you take this
website and if you were to--
I like to shrink it down to the
form factor of a mobile screen.
And your thumb is down at
the bottom of the screen.
The bottom tab navigator
is pretty intuitive.
But on web, you can use other
navigation functionality
that we can demo in class later.
Some of the other prompts
here is a will open Android.
Which one opens iOS?
One of them will.
Well, I probably don't
have a prompt to open iOS,
because I'm running on Linux.
To run on iOS locally
on your computer,
you have to have a Mac because
that's the way Apple designed
their development flow.
But if you don't have a Mac,
and you want to develop on iOS,
there's still a way to do that.
So let's go ahead
and talk about it.
Web is pretty easy.
All you do is npm
start and hit W,
and it'll open up
the website for you.
And you can get
going from there.
Mobile is a little
bit more complicated,
and I'll show that real quick.
The easiest way to
get going with this
is Expo Go app literally
just on your phone.
Go to your Google Play
store or the Apple App Store
and look for Expo Go.
It's got this icon here.
Install that, and
it will give you
a screen that-- and I'll pop
the camera open to show it here.
I've got an Android tablet
here I'll demo this with.
So this is what you'll
see more or less.
I don't know how well that
comes up on the webcam there.
But there's a scan
QR code button.
You pop open a typical
QR code scanner.
And you can scan the QR code.
And you'll see it in
the terminal compiling
Android assets to be able
to serve it up on Android.
And then voila.
I've got the Android app.
I've got that bottom
tab navigator in there,
and that's ready to go.
It's that simple, which is--
for mobile dev, it blows--
for me that's been doing
this for a little while, used
to React Native or fiddling
around with Native Dev,
it's mind boggling but extremely
empowering and enabling.
Again, if you have an iPhone,
but you don't have a Mac,
you can still download
Expo Go, scan that QR code.
And you can develop on
iOS without any burden,
without having to buy a Mac.
So let's look at--
I don't have an iPhone here
that I'm going to demo.
There's one other way
on mobile to run this,
and that is with an emulator.
Android Studio here.
Actually, let's go
to the Expo Docs.
So if you go to the
Expo Docs, search for
Set up your environment.
And you can go down here.
Let's say you want to do it on
an Android or an iOS device,
this is just going to walk you
through getting the Expo Go app.
But let's say you're
on Linux or Windows,
and you want to do
an Android emulator,
or you want to do an
iOS simulator on Mac OS,
you can click those toggles.
And then keep scrolling.
It'll show you how to do this.
Development build requires a lot
more DevTools to be installed.
Again, Expo Go is the easiest
way to get going here.
It's going to prompt
you to download
Android Studio, download SDK.
I've already done this, and it's
a little bit time consuming.
So I'm not going
to take the time
to do it here on the recording.
But the Docs are up to
date and easy to use.
And if you are
running on Linux, it's
going to give you Mac
OS or Windows options.
Really, the big difference
there is how you can--
there might be a couple of SDKs
that are slightly different,
but it'll show you which ones.
But the main difference
is going to be setting up
your environment variables.
On Mac OS, you're going to
update your zprofile or Z shell
RC it says, or bash.
If you don't know if
you're using bash,
you're probably using
Z shell on Mac OS.
Z shell is the default. And
you'll just add this text
to your Z shell RC.
On Windows, it's a little
bit more complicated.
But again, it will
step you through that.
I've got it running here.
So once you've got it running,
you can click this here.
I don't know why that's popping
up on this other screen.
OK, so you can see this
image here on their website.
It pops you up in
SDK manager, which
is where you'll go to
download the SDKs it suggests,
or there's Virtual
Device Manager.
For some reason-- let me
pop open this dropdown.
I'm getting it on
the other screen.
But let's go to
virtual Device Manager.
You can set up a
virtual device here.
And if you click the plus--
that was probably a little fast.
Up here in the top left,
there's a plus icon.
You won't have any
items here by default.
But if you hit the plus, you
can pick a device to emulate.
I suggest getting one of those
that has the Play Store included
in the operating system
image, just because it
has the normal Play Store tools
that you're used to seeing
or that you would expect to
see on an Android device.
You can pick any of these.
I've seen that the fold is a
little bit wonky just because
of the folding screen
emulating that's a little bit--
sometimes, it's a
little unstable.
But you can test your
phone on a large screen,
on a normal-sized
screen, on a tablet.
I think they have a
tablet emulator here, too.
That way, you can test your
app on different screen sizes.
That's mostly what I use these
for, is for different screen
sizes.
Just click on one.
Hit Next.
Get the latest SDK.
It's listed in the Docs.
But right now, that's API 35.
Go ahead and hit
Next and then it'll
name it whatever it is for you.
And then you can click Finish.
I'm not going to, because
these take a few gigs each.
And I don't need
another one right now.
Then you can go
ahead and hit Play.
My graphics card doesn't play
well with these sometimes,
so I get that pop-up.
Yeah, and it is
rendering kind of funny.
Anyway, once it's
done booting up,
you just need to go over
to your terminal, wherever
you have that running.
And then you can
press the A key,
and it will
automatically install
the Expo Go utilities it
needs on your emulator
and run the app on
the emulator for you.
Same with iOS.
It will give you a
prompt in the terminal
to be able to run it
on an iOS simulator.
But on iOS, you would download
Xcode from the App Store
and/or from the
website directly.
And then through Xcode, you
download iOS simulators.
I'm going to go ahead
and stop it for now.
The one downside of
running these emulators
is it's pretty heavy
computationally.
So if you don't have
a beefy computer,
your computer might
struggle to run those
at the same time
as everything else.
Again, one of the benefits--
I recommend going with a
physical device with Expo Go,
just because that's
the easiest way.
And you don't have to
worry about extra software
on your computer.
So that's everything we
need to get going there.
When you're running
on your EC2 instance,
you will be able to access the
web version of your expo app.
If you are wanting to
target mobile specifically
for your app, or even
exclusively mobile,
you will need to clone your
repo to your local computer
and run it locally.
There isn't a way
to do mobile dev
with Expo on Amazon EC2 images.
The reason for that is
because to run Expo Go
and connect to your
local Metro server,
you have to be on
the same network.
And I have tested this on
Blue-- or not BlueZone.
It's not BlueZone anymore.
It's called eduroam, I think.
I did install or connect
to eduroam on my laptop
and on my phone, and I was able
to run Expo Go through my phone
on the eduroam.
I don't know how
that works or how
they are able to see each
other on that network,
but it does work.
But it won't work on
your Amazon EC2 instance.
OK, so I've got
that popped open.
Let's look at routing
at this point.
So we'll pop open this.
It talks about
file-based routing.
And what this means is
usually with React Navigation,
or other web
navigation, you would
have to set up some sort
of routing configuration
so you have extra files that
define your navigation tree.
In the case of expo-router,
you don't have to do that.
You're going to just lay out
your navigation tree in the file
system, and it will interpret
that and build the file trees
for you.
While we've got
this Expo App open,
I'll just step through
what a router layout might
look like for the demo
example that Expo gives us
when we start it up.
We've got the _layout.tsx
inside this (tabs) folder.
The parentheses name
of a folder here
is how they denote a nested
router inside of the app folder.
You could put all of your pages
just directly in the app folder.
But if you have
nested router logic,
then you can organize those
into folders like this.
So inside of their tabs,
they've got their _layout.tsx.
And I don't know why this is
highlighting it red this time,
but it is.
But anyway, they just
put a tab navigator,
and that's what we saw on
the other screen, those two
bottom tabs.
And they defined what screens
those tabs navigate to.
The default one is index.
And so we can open
up the or index.tsx
and see there's the source image
for that image that was up top.
And then they've got some
ThemedViews, ThemedText.
And that's just their
way of styling their text
in wrapper components.
Yeah, we don't want to
spend too much time on this,
because I'm going to--
that one more time.
Pop it open.
It's taking a second
to build the--
compile the web assets.
Yeah, so they say
you can try it out.
You can go ahead and just modify
the index.tsx right inside
of the tabs, like we
were looking at here.
And if you wanted to use
this as a starting point,
you're welcome to.
That would just involve a
little bit more familiarity
with reading the code that
they've got implemented already.
But what I'm going to
do for demo purposes
is npm run reset-project,
like they recommend here,
to start my own
project structure.
So Control-C to quit
that, and then I'll
just paste that in there.
No, I don't need to keep
those example files.
OK, so it--
I went ahead and deleted the
demo files and then started
a new blank project.
So let's look at
what that looks like.
npm start-- let's
run that up again.
We'll open it up again.
And this is all it is.
There's an app bar at the top
and then just a blank-- well,
it's got a text there.
So let's look at our
file structure now.
We've got app.
We've got a _layout.tsx,
which just returns a stack.
So it's not doing any special
routing or any special layout.
And then we've got
this index file.
We've got this view
that's being rendered,
and it has a text inside of it.
So let's look at some
basic component structure
and how this is laid out.
First of all, the index is the
name of this page component.
So this whole page is
the index component,
which is a page since it's
inside of our app folder.
We have two components inside
of our index component, View
and a Text.
Those are just imported from
React Native, like this.
Text is just a tag that
takes text as children.
So you can put any text
in here and edit that.
And as long as your
metro server is still
running in the
terminal, this app
will hot reload anytime you
update your source files.
And then the view has a prop.
The prop is style,
and we're just
defining the flex, which
is a way of saying,
this component should fill
all the space that it can.
And it should take
up-- one is like, I
should get one share of all
the space that's remaining.
And since it's the
only one in here,
it gets 100% of that space.
JustifyContent "center",
alignItems "center"
is why this text is centered
instead of up in the top left.
So if we delete that,
boom, it's up there.
As you're editing
styles in your classes,
you will probably be able
to test and say, hey, AI,
I want this style
to look like this.
And it's pretty good at
laying that out for you.
For your ability to read
and understand the code,
there are a few ways
that it might do this.
One way is just inline.
You can have inline
styles, which
is what this view
has by default.
The other way is to define
a style sheet and use those.
So let's import.
Let's actually
make a style sheet.
So I'm going to do const.
And again, for those that
haven't used JavaScript before,
const is how you
declare a variable that
doesn't get overwritten.
Styles-- styles =.
And then I'm going to
do StyleSheet.create.
And I'm going to--
an object in the middle.
StyleSheet needs to be
imported from React Native.
And then in here,
I can make a style.
I'm going to call this the--
let's just call it
the pageWrapper.
And then I can get this
exact object, put it in here.
And that is defining
that the same way.
So now in here, we can
do styles.pageWrapper.
And now we should have the same
styles available on this page.
And now you can see it's
still centering the content.
And it's taking
up the entire page
because it's centered
across the entire page.
So yeah, for your
ability to read this,
using StyleSheet.create
to define a style
object on the side is the
same as doing inline styles.
Actually, it's usually preferred
to do StyleSheet.create
like this because it's more
efficient when the app is
rerendering multiple times.
So if you can, usually I
prefer to make a style sheet
on the side like this.
OK, so let's look at
modifying this page further
with other components.
You won't need to worry about
memorizing how to do that.
What I want you to focus on is
understanding the concept of,
there are components
inside of components.
And that's how you
make up your page.
You will be able to
just, say, go to your AI
and get help building
whatever you want it to be.
So let's say I have
a new Expo App.
This is my--
I don't even need to tell it
what my index.tsx is so far.
Let's just say I
want a new index.--
and actually, I'm going to do an
index.jsx file since we're not--
I feel like most of you are
familiar with Python than other
strongly typed languages,
like C++ or Java.
So we'll do regular
JavaScript so we
don't have to worry about
types when we write things.
I want a new index.jsx page.
I want the page to
have-- let's see.
Let's just get a form
for registration data.
A form for filling out
user registration data.
I want the form
data to match my--
and you don't have to worry
about connecting to your Django
backend yet, but it is a good
idea, when you're designing
your UI, to keep
your backend in mind
or whatever your whole
project structure is--
Django model.
So let's go grab
our Django model.
OK, so there's my
Django API app.
Here's my model.
Let's grab the user model.
And we're not going
to worry about logic
like submitting the data.
Let's just say for
now onSubmit just
console.log the data for now.
So it's getting some
default values set up
to click that Django data.
They are writing an onSubmit
function to console.log.
And console.log and JavaScript
is the equivalent of--
in Python, you would
just say print.
Personal opinion-- print is
more intuitive than console.log.
[CHUCKLES]
And then the return statement
has this View Controller.
Oh, what?
Are we using react-hook-form?
Very nice.
And then it's defining
styles down at the bottom.
Look at that StyleSheet.create,
just like we had talked about.
And it's setting up the styles
for all the UI elements in here.
And they're giving us
a quick explanation.
We will step through that
here in just a minute.
So let's put that in here.
I'm going to close
this code window.
OK, let's find my app, Expo
app, inside of the app folder,
inside of index.tsx.
So let's just replace that
whole file, or that's 160 lines.
But we'll get through it.
And again, you don't have
to worry about memorizing
how to write all this stuff.
But I do want you to be able
to understand it and read it.
So first things first, it's
complaining about this import
react-hook-form.
That is something we'll have
to include in our package.json
and in our node modules.
And they actually told us this.
They recommended npm
install react-hook-form,
so let's copy that.
For this, you'll
want to be inside
of the same directory as
your package.json folder.
So you can see expo app
is visible where I'm at.
So let's cd into expo-app.
And in here is--
I got the package.json.
So we're in the right place.
Npm install react-hook-form.
And if you do and need
a form in your UI,
which you probably
will at some point,
I do recommend react-hook-form.
It's a nice way to organize
and check form data
and validate your forms.
So it's got that installed,
added two new packages.
And then if we go
ahead and double check,
we can pull open
our package.json
and see react-hook-form
is right there.
So we should be good to go.
And yep, it's not complaining
about that import anymore.
Let's not get too off
in the weeds here,
but let's just step through
to make sure we can understand
what's going on here.
So once again, our
index, our page component
is defined as a function.
And that's how we write
react components now.
In here, this is setting up
form data for react-hook-form.
It's using this
useForm hook, which is
imported from react-hook-form.
And then it built an
onSubmit function for us.
And again, for
readability, this is
how you define a
function in JavaScript.
And you might say,
hey, I thought const
was how you write variables.
You're right.
You can write
functions two ways,
and I feel like this is
important to point out,
so that you can read
and understand the code
that the AI is writing for you.
This is what's called
a fat arrow function.
See, because of that guy right
there, this equal sign bracket.
The other way to
write a function
would be with the
function keyword,
and you could say onSubmit
and put data in parentheses
right there.
This is equivalent to this.
These two functions
are the same.
They have the same
functionality,
and you use them the same way.
In every case except for--
let's say you're going to use
this dot something in here.
Then this keyword functions
differently inside
of each kind of function.
But in this case, we don't
need to worry about that.
Just understand that this is
one way to write a function.
And if you see this
fat arrow function,
this is also a function.
And then the return
statement is a big one
in our index component.
So every component you write
will have a return statement,
every one.
They don't necessarily have to
have functions or variables,
but they will all have
a return statement.
And that returns
your UI components
or your UI elements
for this page.
In this case, we have a View,
which is just a container.
It's a wrapper around
all of our UI elements.
And then it's got a text
that says User Registration.
And let's run this
so we can see what
it looks like as we're
stepping through the code
I find it helpful to be able
to see, oh, this is the code.
And this is how it ended
up looking on the page.
There's our text,
User Registration.
And you will notice this is
centered and bold and large.
And it's just a regular text
component like any other,
but it's got this styles.title.
I'm going to hit Control and
click on that to pop down
to the bottom of the file.
The title has a fontSize
of 20, bold fontWeight.
TextAlign is center.
MarginBottom is 20.
Margin is this gap in
between the User Registration
and the next item down there.
And if you want to see
this, you can go ahead
and open your DevTools.
I'm going to hit F12, and
the elements are selected.
Here you can see the
different UI elements.
I'm going to click
this little arrow.
And then this will highlight
whatever in the UI--
whatever your mouse
is hovering over.
So let's hover over this
User Registration piece
and click on it.
And you can see here, usually--
OK, there we go.
So you can see this
little diagram points
out each piece of the component.
Right here at the core,
the highlighted section
on the screen is all the
space that this component
is taking up.
This component has no padding.
It has no border.
But it does have a margin, which
is null on top and the sides.
But it's 20 on bottom.
So you can see that margin
that's separating this component
from the bottom there.
And anyway, that's
the way-- if you're
wondering why your UI layout
looks funny sometimes,
just pop open F12, open
your developer tools in web,
click this guy, and
inspect your elements.
And you can see, what is
this rendering to the screen?
What is all this style
stuff doing to my layout?
Then we can keep
going down here.
This is an inline
comment, this bracket.
And this /*, that's how you
write an inline comment inside
your return statement.
In Python, comments are
denoted by this guy, pound sign
or the number sign.
I'm going to delete
the comment for now.
And then there's a Controller.
This is part of react-hook-form.
So don't worry about
this right now.
We can talk about
react-hook-form later
if you end up using that.
But what we're looking at is,
this form input has a view.
So it's just that's in order
to be able to style it.
And then it has a TextInput.
This TextInput component is--
it's not popping
over to it, but it
is imported from React Native.
So just like the text and
button and other items,
it's imported from React Native.
And then it has a style.
Placeholder text is--
keyboard's being funny.
There we go.
So this placeholder text, as
you see inside the TextInput,
there's this first name
grayed-out text there.
If I start typing,
that goes away.
And then the value is-- that's
just react-hook-form helping
keep track of whatever the
user has typed in here for you.
And onChangeText is a
function handler, again,
for react-hook-form to
be able to track what's
happening with this TextInput.
And then there's
another TextInput
for the last name input, another
one for the phone number.
It's got a little bit
more validation here.
React-hook-form is-- I'm
going to validate that this
is actually a phone number.
So if I go ahead and type
in something like that
and then try to
submit, it's going
to say that's not a
valid phone number.
This form field
validation is one
of the main reasons you may want
to use react-hook-form, to help
make sure your inputs are good.
And if I change this
to an actual number,
then it's going to say, yeah,
that looks like a phone number.
It matches this regex.
Regex is complicated.
I don't even know
how to write it.
So I just write--
have Gen AI do that for
you, like we did here.
Email is just another TextInput
with some form validation.
It's going to look
for an ampersand
so they don't just
type in nonsense.
And then another TextInput
for favorite color.
Let's say we want
to do something--
well, I don't know
if they have a picker
component in React Native
by default. Let's try it.
OK, so we're going to need
to install another-- yeah,
React Native doesn't have
one out of the box, which
is what I thought.
So let's just copy that
npm install, Control-C.
And I'm going to paste in there
npm install react-native-picker.
And then let's see if it's done.
Yep, it's done generating
that file for us.
Let's go ahead and
copy it in our code--
select all paste.
And now we've got our
phone number, email,
and favorite color is
a picker item, I think.
Let's see.
I don't know if we're
going to have to--
yeah, so once you install a new
packet or a new node module--
let's see.
I stopped this.
That's why it's not refreshing.
npm start.
Refresh OK, now we've got
some colors to pick from.
And we can go look at
the code for that picker.
So we've got this picker
component that we just
installed with node module.
And we have all these.
These are the items
that they can select.
So I love being
able to have access
to node modules like this.
We get this nice
dropdown picker component
we didn't have to build
ourself, getting the UI
to handle the onClick events.
And render this conditionally
would be a little bit of work.
But look, we just did it
with an import statement
for a node module,
and we're good to go.
Now let's fill this out.
And I'm going to hit
F12 to open my console.
So in here, these
are the UI elements.
But this tab here
has the console.
So we should be able to see--
there we go, console.log.
And you can expand that.
And you can see we've got the
email and name and other items
and their values there.
So that's going to be ready
to go once we hook this up
to the backend.
Yeah, that button
has an onPress prop,
which we pass this
handleSubmit function to.
So there we go, console.log.
And eventually, instead of
console.logging the data,
we will pass it to a
network rest handler.
And that will be able
to go to our backend.
So that's all it took
to get a form that we
can submit user data for.
Next time, we'll talk
more about functions
and how to manage local state
inside of our React components
in our UI.
That should wrap
it up here for now.